hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar automating biopharma
quality control to reduce costs and
improve compliance
I'm Judy O'Rourke of lab routes and I'll
be moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by Beckman Coulter
life sciences Beckman culture Life
Sciences develops manufactures and
markets products that simplify automate
and innovate complex pharmaceutical
quality control testing more than two
hundred and seventy-five thousand
Beckman Coulter systems operate in both
diagnostics and life sciences
Laboratories on seven continents for
over 75 years our products have been
making a difference in people's lives by
improving compliance and reducing cost
of ownership to learn more about Beckman
Coulter life sciences please visit
www.cannainsider.com/careers n just
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problem by typing it into
the answer a question box located on the
far left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present today's speaker Tony Harrison a
leader in the pharmaceutical
manufacturing quality control business
for Beckman Coulter
Tonie helvi convener ship of the iso
working group revising iso one four six
nine eight - one and two for microbial
control in clean rooms he served as a UK
subject-matter expert to the ISO working
group that issued the 2015 revised
versions of the ISO one four six four
four one and two documents for clean
room classification at the heart of the
aseptic manufacturing chapters of both
the European GMP and the USA cGMP
documents Toni holds a bachelor's degree
in electrical and electronic engineering
and is employed by Beckman Coulter life
sciences as a senior marketing manager
experienced in water system total
organic carbon toc conductivity and
ozone analysis and cleanroom
environmental monitoring as well as
particle characterization Tony has spent
the last 15 years in applied metrology
for the pharmaceutical and healthcare
manufacturing industries prior to that
he worked for companies providing
process control automation solutions for
manufacturing industries Tony was joined
editor on the is PE guide to ozone
sanitization of pharmaceutical water
systems and was also chief editor of the
PHS s best practice guide for cleanroom
monitoring
Tony is a well known international
speaker and has provided educational
seminars on TOC liquid particle counting
ozone sanitization for water systems and
cleanroom monitoring
worldwide Tony Harrison will now begin
his presentation
thank you for that introduction hello
and welcome to this short presentation
today on automating quality control
testing in the pharmaceutical quality
control department both to help improve
data integrity and also to help reduce
costs
today's presentation will last
approximately twenty minutes plus of
course the time for the question and
answer session at the end this talk
takes a look at four common quality
control procedures and how automation
can help improve the data integrity by
reducing opportunities for human error
whilst also saving time and reducing
operating costs the for quality control
procedures discussed in this
presentation form a common thread in the
biopharmaceutical manufacturing industry
and our water quality testing cleanroom
routine environmental monitoring
variable cell counting and final
injectable drug particulate testing but
first let's take a look at trends in
pharmaceutical quality control data
integrity and also the cost of
compliance
a recent report published states that
79% of all 483 warning letters issued by
the FDA in 2016
cited 21 CFR part 11 data integrity
issues now whilst retraining is a common
response to an FDA 483 warning letter
this may only be part of the solution
was the problem simply that the workers
didn't follow the SOP correctly was it
really that the manual SOPs are simply
not robust enough to prevent future
occurrences of the problem any process
that automates the quality control SOP
can potentially both reduce the impact
of human error on data integrity issues
and also bring welcomed savings by
reducing the time technicians need to
devote to carrying out the SOP
another report suggests that average
pharmaceutical manufacturing facility
spends around 40 million euros per year
on quality control and associated
compliance
you
despite encouragement from the FDA in
their 2004 process analytical
technologies initiative many routine
quality control test procedures in the
pharmaceutical industry remain intensely
manual and time-consuming in the spirit
of the FDA's p80 initiative users could
consider moving from sole reliance on
laboratory based QC testing the using
the online QC instrumentation instead
for example many companies have
validated online water quality testing
instrumentation on their purified water
and water for injection loops but they
continue to rely on time-consuming
laboratory water quality instrumentation
for product release testing as long as
the online instruments can be validated
and meet the requirements the following
appears it makes sense to at least
reduce the amount of laboratory testing
and to rely on data from the online
instruments instead as the online
instruments are automated their use
makes the testing more robust by
avoiding human error and thus improving
data and integrity and at the same time
reducing quality control departmental
costs
a study by the industry bio development
laboratory showed that a greater than
20% variability in test results between
16 experienced quality control
technicians performing the same manual
standard operating procedure now clearly
the man you SOP could be improved and
the technicians retrained but such
variability in results suggests that the
manual process itself is not robust
enough to deliver the required levels of
quality control whilst the technical
specifications of similar QC
instrumentation may appear equivalent
when looking to improve quality control
QC teams should be looking at the level
of automation in the instrument to make
QC testing more robust and repeatable
for example a common source of errors in
QC testing is sample preparation so an
instrument that automates a sample
preparation process can bring enhance
reproducibility and robustness to a QC
test
so let's take a look at our first QC
test quality control testing for
purified water and water for injections
total organic carbon and conductivity
are to the four critical quality
attributes defined for water injection
and purified water in the pharmacopoeias
online analyzers such as the P 8700 from
Beckman Coulter can be validated to
comply fully for both of these key
quality attributes according to the
farmer kapiel requirements
in their guidance the FD are keen to
emphasize that the 21 CFR part 11 ruling
applies only to the data historian where
electronic records are kept the danger
with online instruments with their own
local data historian built-in is that
they could attract the full requirements
of the 21 CFR part 11 ruling analyzes
such as the P 80 is 700 avoid this issue
by allowing the local data historian to
be disabled thus ensuring that it does
not attract the full 21 CFR part 11
requirements as a data archive
electronic records
traditionally dated from the online TOC
analyzers is stored in validated
supervisory control and data acquisition
Knox SCADA or distributed control
systems it makes the process control
improvements challenging because these
systems are validated then adds further
significant amount of change control
more modern approaches keep quote
quality critical data records in a
separate secure archive leaving the
SCADA and VCs systems dedicated to
process control only and far more agile
in support of this the P 8700 can be
configured to automatically send secure
PDF electronic records via File Transfer
Protocol over Ethernet for review and
batch release thus satisfying the FDA's
Alcoa requirements electronic records to
be accurate legible contemporaneously
created original and attributable
now unlike laboratory water quality
testing instrumentation which utilize
reagents and require manual
configuration for it for each sample and
frequent often daily calibration the
online pee 8700 from Batman culture
requires no reagents it automates the
test protocol and only requires
calibration once every 12 months
calibration and system suitability
testing SOPs are automated requiring no
manual data entry and pass/fail reports
are automatically generated eliminating
manual calculations calibration
standards automatically upload their
certified value lot number and the
expiry date to the p80 700 using radio
frequency identification or RFID
electronic chips are located on located
on the calibration bottles when these
are read by the p80 700 automatically
using RFID
okay let's move on to take a look at
what can be done to automate routine
cleanroom environmental monitoring
programs now of course
GMP documents mandate the air quality
conditions for bio pharmaceutical
production and clean rooms but in fact
the real danger is the microbes on the
human body human shed around 30,000 skin
cells per hour all of which are
potential carriers of microbes
unfortunately we do not currently have
technology to detect airborne microbes
real time so where particle counters are
used as a surrogate discussions between
the author of this presentation and
environmental monitoring managers of
facilities across the world highlights
an increasing trend where the burden of
carrying out environmental monitoring is
moving away from the QCD microbiology
team and over to the production staff
for two reasons firstly microbiology
staff are relatively expensive to employ
to carry out such routine tasks and
secondly it reduces a number of people
inside the clean rooms thus reducing the
potential for product contamination
however the production team do not have
the same level of knowledge about
routine environmental monitoring and
this is creating challenges in itself
enlarger biopharmaceutical manufacturing
plants that can be teams of 10 or more
technicians whose job it is every month
to take thousands of routine
environmental monitoring samples the
SOPs and manual and it's each sampling
location have to manually type the
location name into the counter before
they can start counting counters have to
be manually configured following written
SOPs and at the end of each day the
paper printouts from each sample
location have to be photocopied because
the printers in the particle counts are
thermal and the printouts fade over time
and then the results from every location
have to be manually transferred into
electronic format one by one
in an effort to improve data integrity
in routine environmental monitoring
programs Beckman Coulter optimized their
met one particle counting
instrumentation specifically for
pharmaceutical QC use building into the
instrument design the capability for
pre-configured electronic SOPs which
include the instrument setup link
configuration for each location
automatic pass/fail reporting to GMP
criteria and generation of 21 CFR part
11 electronic records straight from the
instrument itself the user simply
selects the electronic SOP that's been
pre-configured in the instrument and
hits the start button and the instrument
configures itself correctly according to
the SOP carries out the correct test and
produces the electronic electronic test
result record all automatically this not
only improves data integrity but can
reduce costs technicians no longer have
to take time collating the paper records
and manually transferring the data into
electronic records additionally by
collapsing the workflow and distilling
the use of air particle counters to
automated SOPs this process facilitates
moving the responsibility for cleanroom
routine environment environmental
monitoring from qualified
microbiologists o to the production
staff further reducing costs
so let's move on to take a look at how
viable cell counting can be automated
cell therapy products in the form of
homogeneous cell populations are
typically enumerated for concentrations
and viability based on the cell's
ability to exclude a super rival dye
such as trypan blue when traditionally
this is done manually using a microscope
and hemocytometer but this method can be
both time-consuming and error-prone
originally designed for counting blood
cells the sample volume used in the
hemocytometer method is typically just
100 nano liters and small errors using
this method cause during the sample
dilution mixing pipetting and visual
enumeration by the technician
present results as the final count
result is multiplied up from nanoliters
to report cell concentration in viable
counts per milliliter and one study
revealed variances in the reported cell
concentration results between each
member of a team of 16 experienced and
knowledgeable technicians using the
hemocytometer method of up to plus or
minus 20% between each technician
in their 2003 guidance on the
implementation of their 21 CFR part 11
data integrity rule the FDA used the
acronym Alcoa where they define good
data integrity practices creating
records that are attributable to the
technician carrying out the testing are
legible are created contemporaneously
original and accurate the USB chapter
1046 indicates that automated cell
counting and viability instruments can
provide a higher degree of precision and
a more reproducible enumeration these
improvements are optimal if the sample
preparation stage is automated thus
reducing the opportunity of technician
errors additionally if the automated
cell counter can use electronic
pre-programmed cell counting SOP
libraries that match the manual SOPs for
cell counting design by the user then
results are more likely to be accurate
and reproducible as well as improving
the precision and reproducibility
automated cell counters can reduce the
cost of this QC test by allowing the
technicians to carry out other tasks
while a counter automates the
preparation and counting stages for each
sample
counters that can count from a 96-well
plates can save significant technician
time helping to reduce QC costs at the
same time by automating the cell
counting SOPs the method becomes more
robust creating the electronic record
contemporaneously improves data
integrity as as the real results are
attributable legible contemporaneously
created original and accurate as per the
FDA's Alcoa guidance in their 21 CFR
part 11 document
finally the last portion for today let's
take a look at the requirements with
particulate testing in injectable drug
solutions and how these tests can be
made more robust although largely
harmonized the requirements for parental
drug particulate testing do vary from
country to country and from product to
product the volume of the sample to be
analyzed and the format that results are
reported in varies from product to
product for example the sampling
requirements are small volume
therapeutic protein products such as
vaccines is different for that at a
large volume parenteral such as an
intravenous drip bag results must be
calculated and expressed in the correct
format for example counts per container
or counts per milliliter
depending on the product on the test
now whilst general-purpose liquid
particle counting instrumentation can be
used for the testing of particles and
parenteral products the Beckman quarter
hayek counters have been optimized for
the application due to the wide range of
complexity in the testing the various
compendium tests are pre-programmed in
the higher software and the hayek will
automatically calculate a pass/fail
result avoiding manual calculations and
as the QC teams tend to use their
product brand name to describe the
product sample and to test the height
particle counters allowed the user to
select the required tests for each
sample by selecting the product by name
from a brand name from a drop down menu
the correct compendium tests for each
product is automatically configured once
the brand is selected and there are no
manual calculations
so I'd like to summarize the key points
of the presentation
while the industry focuses on errors and
emissions in 21 CFR part 11 electronic
records the underlying issue is that the
retraining may only be part of the
solution manual SOPs are not robust
enough to prevent future recurrences of
data errors and emissions QC
instrumentation automate the Quality
Control SOP can potentially both reduce
the impact of human error on data
integrity and also bring whelk and cost
savings by reducing the time technicians
need to devote to carrying out the SSP
so thank you for your time today I will
now take your questions
thank you Tony for your presentation a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them
into the drop down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button Tony Harrison will answer as
many questions as time permits and the
first question is how can the PA t700
toc analyzer from beckman coulter be
validated to support its use for product
release interesting certainly certainly
so in there i chq to document the
tripartite committee from the US PEP and
JP lay down the guidance on how analysts
and sorry
an analytical method should be validated
to demonstrate that it's suitable for
its intended purpose I have a paper on
validating the P 8,700 TOC analyzer to
IC HQ - I will send it to you
you mentioned electronic records in PDF
format are automatically exported from
the P 8,700 TOC analyzer surely PDF
files can be changed so how do you
ensure that the electronic record secure
so there's two main ways in which this
is achieved firstly the P 8,700 uses
secure File Transfer Protocol or FTP
which is an industry standard protocol
for secure data transfer and secondly
the P 8700 automatically applies a
randomly generated password to the PDF
file from xx being altered in any way
looks like we have time for one more
question it is how this rfid technology
prevent manual data entry and
calculations on the P 8,700 thank you so
firstly the P 8700 as all SOPs for
calibration system suitability testing
etc pre-programmed in electronic format
electronic SOP format and when the user
initiates one of these
chronic SOPs the P 87 or 700
automatically reads the calibration or
system suitability certified values the
lot number and the expiry date using the
RFID tags attached to each calibration
standard as the SOP is electronic and
automated the P 8700 automatically
carried out the SOP and calculates
pass/fail or based on the criteria laid
down in the Pharmakon peers and this
avoids both manual data entry and manual
calculations thank you I would like to
once again thank Tony Harrison for his
presentation do you have any final
comments no just thank you everybody for
attending well thanks again I'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we would like to
thank our sponsor Beckman Coulter life
sciences for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through August 21st
2018 lab routes will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye